[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROB HORNER: My
name is Rob Horner.
I am a custom engineer
at Google Cloud.
I've had the
privilege of working
with Sling TV over
the last year,
with some really exciting things
they're doing in transforming
their workloads.
You heard this morning that
a big focus in Google Cloud
is making it easy
to deploy and making
sure you're not locked in.
So the promise of serverless
computing, serverless
workloads to minimize
operations and open-source tools
or managed open
source tools that
really allow you to run
the workloads you want to
and still have the power of
the open-source community
behind that.
I've had the privilege of
working with them for about
a year now and watching
this journey over the last
probably nine months as they
take existing machine learning
workloads, machine
learning algorithms that
had been built previously
and move things into GCP,
and all of the things that they
got to learn along the way,
and we all love to learn
stuff along the way.
So Austin Bennett is
a senior data engineer
with Sling, Sling Media.
And Salma Riazi is a data
scientist also at Sling Media.
And they're going to give us a
little glimpse into the journey
that they'd have over
the last nine months.
So Austin, can you kick it off?
AUSTIN BENNETT: Let's see.
Is this-- all right
cool, so far so good.
Cool, I think he
just covered that.
So I'll walk you through
the agenda to start.
Why is it that we're playing
around with GCP at all,
a bit about our data and
overview of the sort of things
that we're addressing, how we
took things from a local laptop
to virtual machines to using
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
No machine learning project
can work well without data
being where you need
it, so some thoughts
on how to move data
around and migrate
it, a bit on preprocessing
with Dataflow and Beam
and, digging into how to
automate some prediction using
Cloud Composer or hosted Airflow
in the open-source sense.
So for our motivation,
we had used
to be an analytics
group, so just reporting
for things around Sling TV.
But the goal wound
up being, we needed
to support machine
learning workflows
for a bunch of reasons.
The current tools being
managed database services
really aren't great for
machine learning workflows.
So we needed to change our
tooling and infrastructure.
One way I think of
a trade-off that
is needed in a lot of
places is a data warehouse
versus a data lake.
So data warehouse being really
just a SQL kind of engine,
could be your MySQL or whatever
store or some MPP system,
is super familiar to
many people and updates
are really straightforward.
The ability in a data
lake to otherwise work
with machine learning flows,
just read the data off
of some form of, say,
Blob Storage, super
nice for Spark ML and
things like that, so where
to use which system
so you're not
trying to unload your data
out of a database itself.
Also kind of an
origin, our group
was nice and sent me to
the KDD conference in 2017
to keep track of
research in the area.
There you guys may have
come across the TFX paper
on things around TensorFlow
and a really nice way
to productionize
machine learning.
So I was familiar
with that, and eager
to follow the developments, and
have been attentive to that.
Open source, super
cool, I don't like
managed services where what's
going on under the hood
isn't apparent, as well as then
I can really dig into the code
and understand what's going on.
So here's a whole lot
of things that we either
had been using or made
sense to jump into.
And then really
a quick shout out
to these other
things we're trying
to get through the whole
infrastructure and pipeline
to some more even
OPC sort of things.
And then really what kicked
off this process was the Cloud
Next last year, so
where you guys are now,
as well as we as a
group came and saw
all the great things other
companies were doing.
So it made sense to really dig
in and figure these things out.
And Salma is going to share a
bit on our data and background.
SALMA RIAZI: Thanks.
Hi everyone.
Thanks for joining our session.
I'm going to start talking
about the data and background
and the many iterations
we have to take in order
to get to our end-to-end
machine learning pipeline
that we have today.
So how many of you
know what Sling TV is?
Oh, that's so many.
For those of you who
don't know, Sling TV
is an online TV
platform where users
can sign on and watch online
live TV and on-demand content.
And like so many other
subscription services,
we're concerned
with customer churn.
We want to identify the
customers before they churn,
so we can do something about it.
For this binary
classification problem,
we can look at so many
different features.
For example, what
users watched, what
channel they watch,
how long they
watch it for, what day of
the week, and the time slot.
This is just an example.
You can look at
millions of attributes.
So for this churn
prediction problem,
let's assume that we look
at six days of activity
and want to predict
churn at day 30.
For this one user, the user
subscribes on the first day
and watches ESPN
for 1,500 seconds.
And it's a Monday night.
They come back again
on the second day.
They watch Food Network and
it's Tuesday 6:00 to 8:00 PM.
They don't watch
anything on day 3 and 4,
and they come back again and
watch some Travel Channel
on a Friday morning.
For many non-deep
learning models,
this data needs to be
aggregated per user.
So for that one user, you
will have total number
of seconds watched,
channel most watched,
total number of sessions.
Was it mostly a weekday or
weekend, and most common time
slot.
However, this kind of model
will disregard the daily pattern
of user activity.
There are these studies
online, the papers that
use convolutional neural
networks for churn prediction,
and they use daily patterns,
daily activities of users.
The model architecture
for this kind of model
is that it has multiple
convolutional layers, followed
by max pooling, and then it
gets to a fully connected layer.
And then it will get to a final
softmax or a sigmoid output
for the final classification.
I don't see the slides, sorry.
AUSTIN BENNETT: Yeah, the
screen is flickering in and out.
SALMA RIAZI: In order to
use this kind of model,
we need to clarify between days
of activity and inactivity.
So for the days that the
user has been inactive,
we need to insert zeros.
For example for the
days 3, 4, and 6,
we insert zeros for
the numerical values
and encode the categoricals.
Then before feeding this
data into the model,
the data needs to be
encoded and scaled.
For numericals it needs to
be scaled between 0 and 1.
And for categoricals
it needs to be encoded.
So after trying that, we were
able to improve our model
metric by 15% compared to
our baseline on deep learning
models.
For that one sample,
if you look at one user
for six days of activity,
with five features
it's very simple to preprocess
and train the model.
However, with many, if you want
to look at a more granular time
standard, for example
minutes or hours;
and for millions of users
with thousands of features,
this problem gets very
challenging really quick.
So now I'm going
to talk about how
I did the preprocessing
and each iteration.
First I started small
with a data warehouse.
I moved the data to
a virtual machine,
preprocessed and saved the
data on the virtual machine
using Pandas and NumPy.
I'm going to get into the
details in the future slides.
I trained the model.
It was a Keras model
on the virtual machine,
the predictions on
the virtual machine.
The only thing is that
I needed to preprocess
the predictions the same way
that I preprocess the training
data.
And then I saved the predictions
to the original database.
So we realized quickly
that that system,
it was not good for production.
It's not very scalable.
And we wanted to move towards
a serverless scalable system.
So we started changing our
tools and moving through GCP.
First, I started with
an original database,
moved it to Google Storage
and did the preprocessing
on Datalab, using the same
functions and same tools.
I saved the preprocessed
data to Google Storage,
did the training with Keras
on CMLE Cloud Machine Learning
Services, and did the
predictions on virtual machine.
I did this because
last year Keras was not
compatible with the model API.
But I think today,
things are different.
After that, I did
the predictions
on the virtual machine
and saved the predictions
to the original database.
Again, I needed to do the
preprocessing on the prediction
data.
This is detail about the
code I used for the first two
iterations.
First I read the unloaded CSV
file into a Pandas data frame.
Then I scaled and
encoded the data,
and then I set it
an NumPy array,
while inserting zeros for
the reason I showed earlier.
And then I saved the
NumPy and pickle files.
The encoding, I did
the encoding using
LabelEncoder and
StandardScaler by Scikit-learn.
I saved the two
pickle files, which
I needed to keep track of
throughout the modeling
process.
The problems are scale,
the extra packages,
the pickle files, and
prediction preprocessing.
This is how the model
architecture looks like.
If you look at the
first four lines,
I am reading the whole
NumPy area at once.
And then I'm loading
the pickle files.
The problem with
loading everything
at once is that if you
look at the bottom part,
I get an out-of-memory error
in Cloud Machine Learning.
And then after that, that's
just a normal Keras model.
Before solving the out-of-memory
error, while the data was small
I experimented with
hyperparameter tuning,
which is a really cool tool.
You can set your parameters
and experiment with it.
So here, this is a very
exaggerated hyperparameter
tuning example.
You never want to
experiment with this many.
But here I'm trying
to experiment
with number of filters in the
convolutional layers, batch
size, optimizer,
and dropout size.
On the right, you
will see the YAML file
that is submitted
along with the job.
And in there, you will set the
ranges that you want to try.
For example, if you
look at the optimizer,
there is adam, SGD,
Adamax, and others.
On TensorBoard you can
follow all these trials
that are being run.
And based on your model metric,
you can pick your favorite one.
So here on the lower left
pane, I picked number 18.
And on the Google
Cloud Platform,
you can go and find what
number 18 hyperparameters were.
So here the first conv layer,
the number of filters were 112,
and the optimizer was Adamax.
While in TensorBoard, you can
also check the model graph
and see if everything
looks expected
and if anything stands
out for troubleshooting.
So now back to the
out-of-memory error.
I still needed to
solve that part.
So this time I started
with the original database.
I moved the data
to Google Storage,
did the preprocessing
on Datalab,
and saved the NumPy array again.
But this time I converted the
NumPy array to a tfrecord file,
so I could use tf.data
data in TensorFlow
to read the data in batches.
And then I did the
predictions on the model API
in Cloud Machine Learning,
and saved the predictions
to BigQuery.
Again, I needed to do
preprocessing on predictions.
So here's how I converted
the NumPy to tfrecord file.
I used the image example,
which saves all my features
to a feature called x,
which is inconvenient,
because later it will be hard
to get to each feature by name.
But this solved the
out-of-memory error
and the scale issue.
So this is the model input
data and architecture.
First you need a parsing
function to parse
your the tfrecord file.
Here there's x and y.
X is all the features
combine in one.
The input function, it will
read the data in batches
and you can set it to
shuffle your training data.
So just a reminder, this
is where iteration 3 is.
Everything is almost in
Google Cloud Platform,
except for the beginning part,
which is the original database.
And now Austin will
take us through how
he moved that to BigQuery.
AUSTIN BENNETT:
Thank you, Salma.
OK, cool.
So oh, I meant to switch
the order of these slides.
OK, so BigQuery is great.
I mean I talked
about a trade-off
before between a data
lake and an MPP database.
Realistically, BigQuery gives
you the best of both worlds.
Curating data and
needing to think
about the files on a
storage system is a pain
and I don't want to do it.
And I'm glad there's a
managed service for it.
I can update data and
not think about things.
It's as performant as
anything else I've seen.
I haven't needed to
do a ton with it yet,
but the ability to share data
across different organizations,
across projects is
super straightforward.
And I didn't pay attention
enough earlier today as to
whether or not the BigQuery
Read API was talked about.
But it's super cool,
gives us direct access
to the underlying
storage, for then
letting Dataflow, Beam jobs,
or Spark, et cetera; access
that data directly.
A great way to try
stuff out also,
which I wish would have
existed when I first
got started, is there's
a transfer service
that input a few
parameters in the UI, which
I prefer to not use UIs.
But this will get you
moving really quick.
In our case, we moved
a few terabytes over,
and saw that
performance was great.
Given that I just gave you a
great sales pitch on how great
it is, I also like--
everything isn't all
roses all the time.
Right?
So I ran out of resources,
even on BigQuery
in one specific instance.
Although oh well, talking
with the BigQuery team,
eventually we were able to
do this sort of query which
we were able to do elsewhere.
They fixed things, more
or less, and then this
became not an issue.
So ML can't be successful
without ingesting and moving
data around.
So I want to talk
about a few ways batch
ingests from various places,
third party APIs that we
may hit and stream APIs,
and using some various open
source or at least
managed tools.
Also containerization
is pretty cool.
A lot of our stuff
has been orchestrated
from a central
virtual machine, which
although has worked
very well, also
has its problems for scheduling,
resource conflicts, and package
issues and versions.
Those sorts of
things go away when
we adopt these sorts of
containerization practices,
which we've been
working towards.
Many of our batch ingests
are patterns like this.
And also I guess
the point I'm going
to try to get
across in this talk
too is multi-cloud
is totally doable.
Use the great tools
where they exist
or within the confines
of your organization.
If people say you need
to use something, don't--
it's not all or nothing.
So many of our workflows are--
data gets dropped
into S3, for instance.
This is a very simplified
workflow of one,
say, Spark job that
transforms stuff back into S3.
To do things with it, for
instance, just take that output
and copy it over using
the transfer service
or gsutil or whatnot.
And then it's in Cloud Storage.
Another way that
we've played with
is on data ingest in
the first place into S3,
copy it over to Cloud Storage.
Write that Beam or Dataflow job,
get it over to Cloud Storage.
Especially once it's
there and because we're
talking about batch, it's
straightforward to get it
into BigQuery.
Also Dataflow and Beam can
go straight into BigQuery.
And then I put "poof" because
I think I haven't tried it yet,
but I think that there's
zero problem having
Dataflow and Beam
read-write from S3,
and right there, the
things exist to do it.
But I haven't tried it.
But that seems like a great way
to simplify my architecture.
Another bit on batch
ingest, we have
a bunch of third-party
data providers
that we get data from.
So hit the API in
the first iteration.
GKE and a container was
managing everything.
So it would go to BigQuery,
get say the last time
stamp of things, go back to the
API and get the data it needs,
write to storage, and then
we'd use a Dataflow and Beam
job to write things to, say,
BigQuery and Google Storage.
Things got a little
more simplified
when adding Airflow
to the mix, which
then let the orchestration
be in the Composer Airflow
layer, and smaller containers,
and discrete services.
And then we were able
to reduce query costs
from keeping the metadata
itself in Firestore, rather
than in BigQuery and essentially
using Firestore as a metadata
store of the last time stamp, so
just a quick key value lookup.
Streaming data ingests, we have
processes that look like this.
NGINX and LogStash, on premise
endpoints, stream to Kafka,
go to LogStash.
That winds up getting
bashed and written to S3
and loaded into Redshift.
To support our other fantastic
groups and colleagues
we work with, we then wound up
adopting more of the data lake
model, unloading
things out of Redshift
using, say, Spark;
then writing that
back into S3 for columnar bits.
Since we absolutely
have to support S3,
Dataflow and Beam though
can read-write from Kafka
and are able to write to
these other bits first.
Streaming data,
we're still toying
with whether we're going
to get enough value out
of Bigtable itself to let
BigQuery read from Bigtable,
or write to both, or if
BigQuery is going to be itself.
And although Dataflow and Beam
can talk to our Kafka clusters
directly, we went
ahead and just jumped
all the way to having NGINX
and LogStash forward write
to Pub/Sub, because with the
eventual goal being let's
get our on premise
infrastructure into the cloud,
and it looks like we're leaning
towards using Cloud Endpoints.
And Cloud Functions,
although we're first
proving out the rest of
the pipeline that's here.
Big fan of things Beam
and giving a shout out
to this session on Thursday
of my colleagues there,
11:40 to 12:30 Stream
Analytics stuff.
And then Salma's going to
share more on our modeling.
SALMA RIAZI: Thanks.
So now that we have data in
BigQuery, thank you Austin
for putting it in BigQuery,
everything is in the query now.
So now I start from BigQuery.
But again, as Austin
mentioned earlier,
we were at Next
last year, and we
learned about all these
new tools like Dataflow,
tf.Transform that are great for
preprocessing big scale data.
So I wanted to give
those a try, and I
found these courses on Coursera
that are really helpful.
And Datalab is a great tool to
follow the courses on Coursera
and learn tf.Transform.
So this time I started
from BigQuery, then
did the preprocessing
on Datalab.
But with preprocessing
that means
submitting a job to Dataflow.
And then I saved the
preprocessed data
on Google Storage, trained
the same model on CMLE,
predicted on CMLE, and
brought it to BigQuery.
But this time no preprocess for
predictions, so that's great.
Here is a learning example
of tf.Transform on Datalab.
In case you guys
are interested, you
can follow it and
troubleshoot your code.
It's interactive and it's easy
to follow examples, serverless
and customizable.
So here's our final
iteration, which
is much shorter
than the beginning,
and scalable, and serverless.
We start from BigQuery, do
the preprocessing on Dataflow,
save the tfrecord
files on Cloud Storage,
do that training and
predictions on CMLE
and write it to BigQuery.
Here we solved
all these problems
of scale, extra packages,
and no more pickle files.
There is no preprocessing
for predictions,
because tf.Transform
writes the graph.
And you can point your
model to the graph
of the output of
the tf.Transform,
and it will automatically
preprocess it for you.
Here is an example of
Beam pipeline that I used.
First I read the
data from BigQuery,
no more unloading
data from a database.
It just reads it
straight from there.
Second step is grouping
by user, which is just
reordering the elements.
Then I insert zeros and reshape.
I'm going to get into the
details in the upcoming slides.
And then I scale and encode
using the tf.Transform
functions.
And then finally I write
it to a tfrecord file.
These are the first three steps.
The first function is just a
query, just select a query.
The second one is
data validation.
Here I'm checking to see if
days greater and equal to zero,
but it could be anything.
The third step is
collect users, which
it reorders the input elements,
so it can group by later.
The fourth step is the write
format, NumPy operation
function, which is just
a normal NumPy function.
And the fifth step is where the
encoding and scaling happens.
So after the fifth step,
the tf.Transform graph
gets written to
your bucket, where
you can point your model to.
Here's a Dataflow example.
I'm going to show
you a demo later.
But just in case,
here's an example.
You can follow each step
and see where you are.
You can see your job
description and summary.
And on the right middle pane,
you can see the auto scaling.
So here I needed 70
workers for 10 minutes.
It auto scales to 70
and then back down.
And my job was
done in 15 minutes.
So now I'm going to
move to the demo.
All right, so there's
these two files
that are very similar
to what I showed you.
I'm going to run it
from the terminal,
and hope that it will work.
So here's the GCP
platform, the homepage.
Here you can find the
Compute Engine, ML engine;
all these tools that I just
talked about, BigQuery.
But I'm interested in Dataflow.
And one of them has kicked off.
The graph is still
being analyzed.
So we have to wait a little bit.
OK.
So here you can follow
what's happening.
The first step is the BQImport.
And it didn't run.
So in order to check why, you
can always click on the step
and click on the logs.
And it will give you the
error, which here it says,
BigQuery execution failed
because unrecognized name.
I just put an
unrecognized name there.
So you can see the error.
This is the second one,
which is exactly like the one
I showed you before.
You can see the
steps that's running.
I'm running it for my
training data and also
the validation data.
And they all get saved.
Here is where the transform
function gets saved.
And this is where the
transform happens.
The auto-scaling is kicking off.
Here you can see the job
information, and the resource
metrics, and the
pipeline options.
You can always submit
a setup file with it
to specify what you want.
Here's the auto scaling.
The current workers are 0.
But it wants to be 70.
If we weight a little
bit, the current workers
will go up to 70, and then back
down, and the job will be done.
This is the same job that I
showed you the picture before.
So we don't have
to wait 15 minutes.
So I'm going to go
back to the slides now.
All right, so in the
model the only thing
that you need to change is
the serving input function.
Where you point it to the
tf.Transform graph output.
This is how it happens.
And then the lower is
the predictions output,
where there's viewer
ID, probabilities,
and prediction classes.
So now that we have all the
pieces of the puzzle together,
it would be great if we could
have this automated daily,
so we could have daily
predictions every day.
And here's Austin, who will
tell us how he did that.
AUSTIN BENNETT:
All right, so cool.
Things should be
automated and whatnot.
We're doing batch predictions.
One of the more straightforward
ways of doing it
is unload from BigQuery to get
those records in new line JSON
format.
In this case, we
used Beam Dataflow.
Write those to
Google Cloud Storage.
A second step being hit the
ml-engine predict service, read
those files from Cloud
Storage, write them back
to Cloud Storage, and
then just for what we've
been doing those batch results
are just going into BigQuery,
so we can do things with them.
So it's a three-step process.
To highlight what this
is, we have our Beam job,
which is called extract.py.
The documentation is super
straightforward on how
to use Beam Dataflow
to do some things.
Composer Airflow less
so, for these operators,
I'm really hoping they wind
up getting accepted for--
I forget, if it's summer
or season of docs--
where then there should
be some resources helping
even the open source projects
get some documentation going.
But you can take more or
less the Python command line
and translate that into
what's needed for Airflow.
This is for the
Dataflow operator.
Equivalently, hey,
we see a whole lot
of variables we're using and
using gcloud ml-engine job
submit, again
documentation really great.
And here with the ml-engine
batch prediction operator,
you can see I tried to make
this pretty straightforward,
where it's pretty much
plug-and-play here.
And the same goes for the BQ
command line tool and the load
command; a little bit more
to it, but also again,
pretty straight forward.
So that's how we weaved
these things together.
Yes, they can be Cron jobs
for those sort of command line
tools that we saw.
But Airflow Composer gives us a
lot more visibility into stuff.
And also, hey,
let's learn these,
because those lessons get
applied all over the place,
like we saw earlier for
moving batch data around.
OK, so, so far summary, we've
seen how we slowly built
onto our eventual solution.
The real goal was how can
we have in our toolset
the best scalable solution that
we can work on even with, say,
our 12 gigabyte
data sets when we
need to work with our
mini terabyte data sets,
and anything in between.
But hopefully as
you've seen, you
don't have to not show any
progress for a long time.
While you figure
things out, you can
work towards those solutions.
Using TensorFlow stuff, we've
seen better predictions,
trying to get that across, and
you can use open source tools.
And also we're a
very small group
that we've been working
with, so leveraging
serverless and managed
services are amazing,
so we don't have to.
Quick announcement, also
I'm helping organize
the Beam Summit in Europe.
If you're into Beam Dataflow
for even running things
like TensorFlow Transform,
check this out in mid-June.
Also there will be
Beam Summit track
for two days in
September in Vegas
at ApacheCon, another
place to check stuff out.
And then wanting to say thanks
to a bunch of people, so
especially our Sling
and Dish colleagues
for encouraging and supporting
this path, either directly
or by supporting the
needs of the group.
So we had the time, and
ability, and attention
to devote to these
sorts of things.
To the GCP team that's helped
us along this journey, certainly
thanks to the open source
tools and everybody,
either paid or volunteer in
these open source communities,
and you guys for your attention.
[MUSIC PLAYING]